uh alex writes this is really ugly stuff  by the way you may want to get the kids  out of the room alex writes  you want to call out white supremacy  fine do it  but what about jewish supremacy is it  because you were jewish and a supporter  i am not anti-semitic  at all  but if you seriously think we're not on  to what's really going on here  and who's really in charge of this  globalist plot  then you're wildly mistaken  at least trump tried to fight these  globalist internationalists i should  actually be using the alex jones  globalist internationalist trotskyite  socialist shun like obama trudeau macron  and the rest of these zio bish  this is anti-semitic